one of my closest girlfriends is here
jessica mulrooney
and meghan markle is remaining loyal to
her dear friend
despite mulroney's recent controversy
with influencer sasha
exeter a source tells et that the
duchess of sussex has remained
in touch with their longtime friend
quote while jessica's comments may have
been
misguided and tone deaf meghan has not
given up on her
i realized the only wrong thing to say
is to say nothing last month the
canadian stylist
spoke about her relationship with megan
in a since-deleted post
writing i'm going to tell this once and
for all
megan and i are family she is the
kindest friend
and has checked up on me every day
tabloid culture is atrocious
it creates lies and hurtful storyline
stop
feeding into it done it's the more that
you engage with things that
are negative not just for other people
that you might not know
but what it's doing to you as a human
being will really have lasting effects
our source confirms that megan and
jessica do still talk
adding quote jessica publicly apologized
for the controversy
and has been on a journey to better
herself and become aware of the
unconscious bias that exists
in society of course the tv personality
came
under fire in june for her feud with
exeter amid the black lives matter
movement
jessica mulrooney took offense
to a very generic call to action that i
shared on my ig stories
and what happened next was a series of
very problematic
behavior and antics that ultimately
resulted in her sending me a threat in
writing
last wednesday june the third the
influencer alleged that mulroney had
used her quote
textbook white privilege to send her the
written threat
listen i'm by no means calling jessa
racist but what i will say
is this she is very well aware
of her wealth her perceived power
and privilege because of the color of
her skin mulroney publicly
apologized and took some time out of the
spotlight
to reflect learn and listen the 40 year
old ctv
show i do redo was cancelled as a result
of the scandal
dma's fashion contributor jessica
mulrooney
she also lost her contributor status on
good morning america
due to the backlash it's the ripple
effect
at the time a source told e.t that the
duchess was taking a step back from her
friendship with mulroney
calling her comments unacceptable and
offensive
as you're out there building your brands
as you're out there engaging with your
friends
online just be conscious of what you're
doing
and understand that it is not limited to
that one moment that you are creating an
echo chamber for yourself
the source added that megan's friends
had been concerned for some time
that jessica had quote been profiting
from her relationship with megan
and using it to further her brand
meanwhile the former actress
and her hubby prince harry have been
lending their voices to call for
change and social justice around the
world in recent months
this juncture if we aren't part of the
solution we are part of the problem
last week marked the couple's locate
launch of their archwell foundation
website
with a source telling et that they've
hit the ground running
despite not officially announcing the
debut of archwell.com
we're a fantastic team we know we are
the source adds that while
there's no formal launch expected in the
near future
their work is quote already underway and
archwell is already an
operating organization but it's not all
work
and no play for the former royals the
source tells et that while megan and
harry are finding their work
incredibly fulfilling they're also
enjoying their family time
adding that it's been quote refreshing
and wonderful with archie
being in montecito hey look an
anteater that's no ant eater
that's a brachiosaurus let's turn the
page
what's next
the source says that the sussex are
looking forward to their future
it's magic it's pretty amazing and
i mean i have the two best guys in the
world so i'm really happy